Tensions over Taiwan have soared.
A visit from House Speaker Nancy Pelosi...
…and comments from other U.S. officials about the island...
…have infuriated China.
The self-ruled island has grown into a durable democracy...
…and major semiconductor producer.
The U.S. has promised to help it defend itself.
Are you willing to get involved militarily...
...to defend Taiwan if it comes to that?
Yes.
But the problem is, China sees it as part of its own territory...
…and has threatened to seize it if necessary.
Over the past year, the Chinese military has also sent dozens of planes,...
…bombers, and fighter jets into the airspace close to Taiwan.
So as Taiwan is perhaps the most explosive issue in U.S.-China relations,...
...here's how we got here and what's next.
The first thing to know is that Taiwan, which is located off China's coast,...
…has been self-governed since 1949.
That's when the Communist Party took power in mainland China...
…and some nationalists fled to the island.
For China, Taiwan is seen as always been the one that got away.
When the Chinese Communist Party first founded the People's Republic of China,...
…Taiwan was never a part of the People's Republic.
Instead, it was governed by the Kuomintang Party...
…that had fled to the island after a brutal civil war.
Ever since then, every Chinese leader has sought to reunify Taiwan with the mainland.
And that includes President Xi Jinping who has made bringing Taiwan...
…under mainland control a key goal of his legacy.